sometimes you need a really obnoxious
sort of like hey you yeah no I was gonna
say go yourself but that's not
appropriate
I'm sung one show I'm a voice actor and
I also have a youtube channel called Pro
ZD I do short skits and nerdy stuff and
basically whatever I feel like doing
much sanderoff you are behind all this
you should wish I you rub your mother's
eyes I'm gonna do some voices and try to
describe how I do them I may not be the
best guy to ask for how do you properly
physically do all these voices I kind of
just go with my gut but you know that's
okay they already asked me here so too
bad I get asked a lot to do kind of like
these grand old king or God voices the
first troll ever did was a Zeus in a
game called the pantheon and he's kind
of this sort of gravelly sort of old
voice of the audacity to invade my
kingdom how would I describe how to do
that I always try have a little texture
a little growl to it only is that
because what a brother that's the sort
of growl you can kind of inject into a
specific voice there was a game called
the hat in time I voiced the owls in it
in that game they were these he's very
nervous little owls they were just tiny
little guys and so my voice goes up
quite a bit in pitch give it a little
shaky quad oh oh no I'm very nervous
about what's what's going on because the
characters were so small and nervous
that sort of shaky quality I felt was
very important pitch wise you can kind
of go up and gonna talk like this sort
of a higher sort of hey I'm kind of like
a protagonist kind of voice that kind of
range higher range you can go up there
and then if you go up there and then
kind of go even higher and more cartoony
and then nervous you gotta get that sort
of little little owl voice so I have a
deep voice and so often times I'll get
asked to do deep voice characters I've
voiced a character named Toro in nomads
of nowhere a rooster teeth animated show
and Toro is kind of a he's like a more
confident version of me so they wanted
him to not sound super growly instead
they wanted him to sound very casual
very very notice I'm doing this without
even realizing it so oftentimes in the
with physicality sometimes comes into
play like with this my I instinctively
put up my arms like this he's kind of a
big beefy guy yes I mean yeah thank you
for noticing
with that kind of deep voice and then
you can kind of make a dopey er if you
want you can plan for like Oakland
accent on it and then he's kind of a
little more if you're doing this kind of
Tony it's a friendly a kind of guy hey
it's me your pal
but then you can also kind of go I don't
know stereotypical like err like the big
guy oh yeah boys I'm gonna beat out of
you that kind of voice so a lot of times
in cartoons you hear voices and a lot of
those voices are actually just
impressions of classic actors like a
very popular one is Edwin thank you papa
sort of this kind of voice it's you have
sort of a lisp on you boy thin a very
whimsical quality Pat Buttram sort of a
sort of a southern kind of kind of boys
oh sure mouth you can do that for a like
a prospector or something like yessiree
got a little uh spittle to it you can
make it look short of a prospector kind
of voice sometimes you want to play like
a snooty character and I like to do
what's basically it's not a British
accent but it's more like a like a
mid-atlantic accent so it's sort of this
kind of voice it's very very dignified
very precise with its pronunciation and
its diction so when it's time to play a
character with more of a regal presence
it's you have to really focus you have
to really focus on your words if you
want to do like an old-timey voice like
I'm talking like it's the Colgate Power
Hour with that sort of old 50's sort of
announcer type boys
you really let that sort of texture
going on words like boys when you watch
old movies and you think everyone sounds
kind of weird it's because they're all
doing Mid Atlantic accents it's like a
weird almost like fake accent that
they're all doing because they think
that's how people should sound there's
common misconception that it's about the
voice but I would say the acting is the
most important part even if you can do
lots of different voices it doesn't
matter
unless you can also act I'm not sure
this was helpful at all but I had fun
doing it if you feel inspired to pursue
it yourself and I think I think you just
gotta practice just gotta get out there
and perform and do it it's the easiest
would it start us just are doing it self
[Music]